welcome to glorious days subnautica
space what it go away what are those
I don't like it back to pod alright so
now we have ton of things look how many
things we have hopefully I can make
something useful out of this I want the
proof Locker
you never know when you need it we're
making good progress in this game not
gonna lie
feel pretty good about it I want to make
a mobile vehicle BAM but I don't know
how to make it that's so unfair life
suck I will make myself a Spadefish and
eat it
hopefully I'll feel better yes yes so
today the goal is to oh god I don't chew
with my mouth open like that just so
we're clear disgusting
we're gonna build our base today and I
I'm trying to figure out I know I had
this stuff I know I have the sub I just
need our rebreather that's what I need
so I need the wiring kit which I can
make yes mine mine yes hold up I need
one thing I need oh god it's dark I
don't want to go out when it's dark do I
wait we go we perseverance no I changed
mine it's too dark I'm scared damn I got
scared last episode okay it can wait it
can wait it can wait so we can make
another base somewhere is that it where
would I make the other base then cuz
look I can make another foundation now
but it wouldn't make sense to build that
at the same spot can you be quiet oh we
have a message Aurora
this is Sunday McGann we just picked up
a massive debris field at your location
yeah I didn't know how bad
how many of you I didn't know yeah you
didn't know now you for that one root
you're my usual baby we're sad silly boy
home something about yeah eat it
son be what else can I say what the only
time I had to rig this big on a rock
that small was in VR and so are all the
others well we know you freaked up
vineya oh god my eye there's too much to
do and I can't focus on one thing we can
just make a rebreather to do that we
just need fiber mesh which is relatively
easy to get but I also really want to
build my house so I'm a bit I don't know
what to do I feel like it makes sense to
build a base somewhere else so I'll make
a base right where I really like there
so that seems to be a lot of materials
which I don't remember where I'll find
it don't worry gamers I'll find it I
think it's towards the ship actually
it's a little spooky here I'm not gonna
lie it's a little spooky spooky that's
okay
eggs should we check for eggs on the
giant Taylor Swift
[Music]
when do I get a friend in this game I
feel lonely
I need my Wilson if you're not I mean
all I have is tastes way over here
alright let's check for eggs do got eggs
yeah thanks you're useless useless okay
so I know there's a cave here somewhere
I just don't remember it's over there so
we can build a base above it maybe that
makes sense to me at least but I I don't
have brains so I don't know help me I
guess it makes sense to have many bases
all your base are belong to us
epic old school reference very nice
Felix thank you okay here we build a
base are you serious I can't build a
base where do I build the frickin base
then on the ground
no can I really build base on ground
that's crazy oh my god what
I just built bass all right what's next
what do I do with this I'm not just
gonna build tubes what can i connect it
together what's the goal yeah pumps
oxygen from a powered to a pipe Network
okay
multi-purpose room ingredients unknown
of course cuz that's what I need really
so really I'm not ready at all Hey look
they love each other
lame hey don't block me don't block me I
need swims okay I'll just make the
better gas mask for now until I figure
out how to build in this game
probably should have done before I
started this god damn this game is
gorgeous what's going on over there
it's not just a cloud or something
what's going on over there what is that
so far no sharks I'm happy about that I
feel good about that don't like sharks
not a fan of it so now we can make
bing-bong bing-bong a comp ass I don't
need a comp ass I need fiber mesh oh god
I need two more I need two more
now we can make a rebreather so which
means we can dig deeper in the water we
can go deeper now that's good right
deep good right I don't know is that
better yeah yeah it's definitely better
100 percent while we're at it let's make
a compass as well actually that might be
useful it's not as a compass work I just
oh cool it just I just have it Oh
awesome I should have made that sooner
so now we should be able to dig deeper
which means more materials to this means
more epic thank you thank you thank you
god damn it's dark though I don't like
this all I need radiation to be here so
I need to swap the helmets
yeah I know I have the radiation suit no
I don't what happened to my radiation
suit
I dropped it by accident I dropped it
are you kidding me no I thought I'd put
it on I'll find it I'll find out I'll
find it I'll find it
I'll find it I'll find it I'll find it
it's cool it's cool I'll find it
no where is a is that it yes yes I got
it I would kiss you I love you so much
kiss me yeah I'm going back to sleep
this sucka cool so we figured out that I
can't go deeper I want to go back to
sleep now I want to go back to sleep
that's what I wanted to do let's make a
battery when the mornings gone you can't
go on bad ring don't know what the hell
to do at this point
oh my god what is I'm choking in let's
rub our clothes for looks I don't care
say your last prayer choke fish I choked
you ooh let's swim down here okay ooh
today this oh so pretty
something hurts me something here taught
you it's you
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh gold I need to heal I'm alive all
right well now I know where to find
those all right I want to get out now Oh
God I gotta hurry up oh gosh I got air
yet how are you Mary already I'm not
descending I am NOT ascending that it's
all right I have an old Swedish trick
the old Swedish Drake baby that's right
when I Spit on you today
haters said no bueno I said eh eh and
they go Oh Jimmy here we go again
dude this is a freaking sulfur mine dude
you oh yeah that's another thing I don't
like added to the things I don't want to
meet in this game octopus
I have never high iodine high iodine
what
did I take damage or something I didn't
know I didn't even I lost some of my
belongings come on dude let's make this
so I have it next time god dang what a
big blunder dude come on we had so much
stuff can I grab it again oh yeah this
is the place okay I'm not gonna go there
is that a flip an egg dude it's a
jacksepticeye egg yes
theirs are super rare he rarely legs
lays any eggs that's what I was gonna
say okay so I should be able to go
deeper now within at this area at least
goddamn I have a lot of stuff
dude I'm rich dude okay I need that
orange table stuff let me know if you
can find it just scream orange table
stuff yes this is Dora the Explorer now
you're not helping Orange table stuff
come on there used to be everywhere
Orange table stuff thank you
for nothing
[Music]
okay I cook food now delicious who
doesn't like to eat boomerangs am i
right gamers only real gamers understand
so now I should be able to make I
literally had the memory of a fish where
are they
advanced wiring kit yeah because I can
make a computer chip I just need the
gold I know I have gold somewhere mmm
yes I feel like I should start
organizing these now you are okay we
made a computer ship as you do from what
their stuff we need want more gold are
you kidding me
come on game you're testing me so I have
gold yes I do
thank you dolphin that isn't in this
game why are there no nice creatures in
this game alright now we made advanced
wiring kit for I don't know why I made
this I I literally have no idea
whoa they just spawned in what a weird
glitch all right that's my beautiful
base thank you so I want to see if I can
go to 100 swept it no I can't do that
this is I really want to explore down
here but I don't have enough oxygen okay
we're not doing that all right we're not
doing that don't be greedy Felix oh I
keep forgetting I haven't checked this
out let's do that then of course sorry
okay I'm coming
pee pee poop is on the way now god it's
getting dark I don't like that then we
explore this already
[Music]
don't like this don't like this yeah
we've been in here so did I miss
something Hey look it's me my natural
state of a habitat hey I can build a
trash can
yeah yeah all right we got a message all
right what is the same hello this is
Sunbeam you know Aurora we're from a
little trans gov on the far side of
inter Amida and we had a saying there
there's no bad without the good no good
without bad
sounds like you tasted a bunch of the
former that only means you're overdue
we'll hold onto the ladder be people it
might just be where we're scanning for
somewhere to park we'll be in touch when
we find it Sunday Maps
okay what if we built this and some
pipes
[Music]
and somewhere and somewhere I think man
montoursville
okay that is a lot of pipes to be fair
and some more pipes okay do I know what
I'm doing absolutely I know what I'm
doing apologize write something nice in
the comments now or else I'm not gonna
die you're gonna die sorry that was a
little mean I mean okay why does this
sound like the stomach is always
grumbling in this ocean
oh yes Taylor Swift I forgot hey hey hey
can't block them if I can't block them
then I don't I don't want to smoke with
them if you know what I mean okay so
where's my area there it is that's my
area okay we will do the thing now we
will do the thing I never done this it
could be awesome we will place it here
right yeah okay
I'll replace it yeah how do I please
does it have to connect to something
floating device yeah and how do I place
it I think I did it okay and then we put
the pipe oh I see I see oh I see oh I
see
[Music]
so can i suck on the pipe right i can
suck on the pipe right oh yeah we're
gonna suck yeah but I got the second
pipe I got the second plant or does this
need to be connected to a base or
something maybe that's it
cuz I can I suck on you I can't suck on
it
gamers confirm I can suck on the pipe
okay that's cool so now we can like
access alright you're sucking a bit my
channel now we can access deeper areas
all right imagine if we get even more
suck in pipes
that'd be hella awesome I just gotta
make sure I can find my way back to the
second pipe I've already lost the second
pipe I'm not even joking oh yeah oh yeah
okay so I see a cave down there where
what what oh my god what is that all
right we gotta explore that how I not
find that sooner there's a flippin
island there what
no more water for me thank you
okay what's that scanning time we can
build a cyclops what in the world is a
cyclops
no no cannot identify be quiet I'm not
speaking to you if I can find a cave
here
I'm definitely setting up there's a cave
okay perfect this means we set out the
sucking
oxygen efficiency decreased what is go
away this is my sucking pipes
alright fight me he's got a freaky cape
dude oh dubstep monsters don't like them
hey hey
so let me suck let me just suck let me
shut up no stop that I will go in here I
don't care I'm out of suck I'm out of
suck
I shall brew this I will go in here this
is my cave now mine mine mine I'm far
away from home and
nice when there's steam and Singha stand
I'm out I'm out I'm done I don't like
this it's stressing me out like crazy
dude I don't want to do this I don't
even I don't know I don't even like
capes I don't even like capes I don't
like kids I just got a I just get I'll
just gotta get back to my when I was
it's fine there's my suck hole it's all
good it's all good just suck it oh oh oh
it tastes so good it tastes like Aaron
Mayer you know thinks the good takes the
good taste the good taste the good
I'm out I changed my mind I changed my
mind I changed my mind
I changed my mind hey I need this go
away you stinky Pokemon your country
stands at three million credits I'll pay
back don't worry gamers I need water
God ironic isn't it I need the the water
fish where are the water fishes are
these the water fish there there these
are the water fish I choked you
I will so Thursday after all that water
do I not have bleach I need coral to
samples all right let's just drink this
for now what Oh No Oh No
okay that's that's good I think I'm at
the point in the game I just need to
scan things more to unlock things I
could be wrong but oh I need those
come here let me choke you yeah do you
like that but you like that more hey
pervert look perfect scanning oh we can
make that okay
epic can I make it can I make it though
I can't
yes oh epic all right we're making that
ASAP oh yes gonna make a tube oh yeah
pretty much
not gonna lie down straight up vibing
give me a loop give me a loop I know I
got it in saitama to get my loop game
add a loop final harvest loop
yes yes
I had me to murder it
Luke
copper wire I have it somewhere in my
neatly organized I guess I have I did
have a comprar come on baby I want to
make this so badly
yes we can do it there she blows star
she blows ladies this will increase your
effective exploration I know
Barris my foundation I've been looking
for this
that was the goal of this episode right
to build stuff I will do it I just want
to try it cuz I don't know how it works
so now I can build this it's building
and now I can build this build it
emergency power only oxygen production
of life yeah yeah yeah that's what they
all say MRI gamers ah so that's what
this is for so can i connect their air
to that I forgot I had this now all we
did even have some math dude whoa what
what what Mamma Mia that's not how I
want to build a day yeah I want to build
it here like a media
yeah glass yeah class
yeah glass Sugoi hmm okay what could be
mush okay I'm just building all kinds of
stuff here
oh yeah it's gonna look good I think I'm
out of materials okay all right that's a
pretty sexy thing damn this is so
awesome
okay so this is the different biome
iPhone
Jesus
it's a jellyfish let me scan you new
jelly smelly belly that's so cool you
know what are we doing jellyfish in
Sweden we chop it up beep up be dead a
goal I'm rich now what's this lithium I
think I need that for something
obviously otherwise it wouldn't be in
the game Felix okay all right cool
good I'm glad you're listening what's
casting that shadow this is this is this
is not mine
okay I got some data for me here's my
glorious base we are going to connection
air to it now so now I can breathe
excellent I need the choking fish I
think I see it no don't kill choking
fish
don't kill him yeah wait what the hell
are you rain oh hey okay all right I
don't like right now okay I connected
pipe to a surface looks good yes this is
what I need a reactor
yes reactor
I found it mom my mom was watching this
playthrough being like yes finally I get
the recognition I deserve thanks mom
that better be titanium mom oh my god my
dogs are psycho I have to I want to keep
playing I want to keep playing I want to
keep playing you can't stop me fine you
win you win you win you win you win you
win freaking flying smiling what oh my
god there's so much to build in this
game I scan it
oh let's scan it now get the skin and
skin or scan it look at that dude look
at that dude
what are you doing is he stuck oh no not
stuck oh sorry sir sorry
I said sorry Jesus
what problem is c/o power transmitter
fragment yes my favorite I've been
looking for that yeah yeah yeah I know
extends the range of power source okay
I need another bioreactor dang it
alright now we build the solar panel
here here build it alright does it
empower now oh my god I did it see yes
this is our new home I found it
noise noise oh you betrayer oh oh oh all
right what do we got
Oh again give me give me yes what
happened to the lights
well what they smacky scan e and then is
Kenny nannies Kenny oh oh I like it I
like it
oh titanium titanium quiet lady no.1
speaker you what is going on here whoa
did you guys see that understand
understand not supposed to be here
understand don't want to be here anyway
understand well well well what do we
have here a time capsule what
what am I gonna do with this okay I have
a bunch of stuff in it how do I enter
without you know what never on thank you
thank you okay so now what we can do is
we can do mere things okay can be the
here please Thomas huge okay nice
are another locker nice it's the
equivalent of building your second
minecraft base I think yes and we can
build the radio RORO we're approaching
the planet we're landing site for you
that's well it's better than the
alternatives we've sent you the
coordinates it'll take us a couple of
days to align our orbit should be able
to establish direct contact with you
during that tunnel and we're coming in
to get you cross your fingers for the
weather rose
don't leave us wait okay so that damn
that's pretty soon dude guys I'm about
to do the coolest thing in the whole
world and I've waited years for this
year's watch this no no why why can I
not to build my aquarium
nope where do I build a nah I have my
really really shitty base set up it's
good enough for a star if you enjoyed
this episode please smash like and I see
you guys subscribe I see you guys smash
like see you guys tomorrow hey hey hey